you got any batman fans here simple yes  is fine just do this up in the audience  well right now director Christopher  Nolan's filming the new Batman movie  Dark Knight Rises  yeah he's filming it earlier earlier  this week some amateur pictures and  videos from the set were leaked online  so the director the producers are all  upset because this video got out now I'm  sure the movie will look amazing when  it's done when they've treated the  footage and they've done all the special  effects but when you see the raw  unedited footage it really doesn't look  very impressive check out this footage  that someone took secretly of Batman  fighting the super villain bane  dude can you believe this so cool  [Applause]